russia says international chemical
weapons experts will be allowed to visit
the site of a suspected chemical attack
in syria tomorrow that would be about
five days after the US Britain and
France struck Syrian government targets
our Seth Doane is the only American
network correspondent to see the site of
the alleged Syrian chemical attack he
reports from inside duma on what
inspectors may find rebel forces had
held duma since nearly the start of this
war and the government fight to take it
back was fierce we got the chance to see
what militants left as they fled just
days ago we've just been brought into
what we've been told is some sort of
bomb factory syrians in their Russian
allies sifted through the enemy stock
pile you can see bins filled with
mortars here there are shells around all
over the ground just above us some sort
of artillery or rocket launcher these
are the the makings of a war while
Russian airpower enabled Bashar
al-assad's forces to win the fight the
rebels used what they could to fire back
[Music]
Russian and Syrian forces airstrikes
in many cases there was very little
access to basic things like food and you
can see the need here today we met this
mother who'd been waiting for bread
the rebels wouldn't allow us to leave
she said retaking duma means the syrian
government now controls the building hit
in that suspected chemical attack which
sparked those coalition airstrikes this
is your brother here massa hun hun told
us his brother Hamza died in the attack
and took us to where he says the gas
came from a missile that struck the roof
the scene now has been cleaned up and
when weapons inspectors finally make it
here they'll find not only time has
passed but plenty of people have passed
through it too for CBS this morning
Seth Dome duma syria so important to
have set there on the ground to show us
what has been going on in the seven-year
conflict